this morning we're taking on a wild
adventure in the forest of washington
states a revolutionary new technology is
allowing conservationists to track big
cats like these cougars they're cute
aren't they in real time to monitor
their behavior i love their eyes the
technology got its start in africa where
it helps fight illegal poaching and
avoid conflicts between wildlife and
humans
ben tracy trekked down into the deep
rainforest of the pacific northwest to
see exactly how it works
it's just after sunrise on the olympic
peninsula a few hours west of seattle
[Music]
we're not here to sightsee pilot and
biologist jeff wells is searching for an
elusive set of targets in the woods
below us right there it's called misty
and grey right
that's where we're going so there's
three potential cats that we're looking
for but they're not just any cats using
these antennas wells picks up radio
signals from collars worn by three wild
pumas or cougars as they're called in
this region
jeff sends the location to the team on
the ground
well this is not bad for the weather
and now mark elbrock starts his own
search
he's the director of the olympic cougar
project at the global conservation group
panthera he's getting him straight up
andy along with partners from the elwham
tribe he's taking a team up this
mountain to find a five-year-old puma
named omar his collar is wearing out and
needs to be replaced
without it the big cat won't show up in
earth ranger a cutting edge digital
tracking platform that has changed just
about everything for the conservation
community earth ranger provides us a
visual tool to just see in live motion
all the animals on the landscape i can't
even exaggerate how big amount much time
we were investing in doing all this
stuff to figure out where cats are all
of that's automated now
technologist jess leftcourt helped build
the system it records the location of
the animals every few hours and we can
then visualize it in real time on top of
a map what does knowing where all the
animals are allow you to do allows you
to protect them and find them in real
time two elephants inside the vents
area
earth ranger was first developed in
africa four years ago to fight elephant
poaching it also helped prevent
conflicts with local residents who would
often kill the massive animals if they
wandered into farms or villages here's
omar's latest location the technology is
now being used in more than 40 countries
on five continents including here in the
remote coastal rainforest of washington
state he is upslope from us okay
we have about a 1200 foot climb to the
ridgeline but we're fairly certain at
this point that we want to make you hike
uphill we're going to keep buying
this so-called hike is more like a
lung-searing death-defying
hand-over-hand assault on a 45-degree
cliff face crowded with trees
when we finally catch up with the dogs
they've chased omar up a tree
okay
elbrock gets ready to fire a
tranquilizer dart but before he can
here he comes here comes
omar makes a break for it
so how often does this happen where you
find one but he gets away oh
too often
so this is what we do he'll probably he
won't run far a couple hundred yards
right
off we go
it's what they do but why the cougar
population is not endangered in this
area
at least not yet
right here on the olympic peninsula they
appear to be isolated from the remainder
of washington state and so the
interstate five it's kind of like a
noose and it's turning the peninsula
into an island they'll be contained and
they'll be breeding opportunities
amongst themselves but over time that's
a terrible thing so basically the
genetics get messed up because it's
essentially inbreeding
exactly in breeding
that's a problem because cougars are
considered ecosystem engineers in these
forests their kills providing food and
even shelter for hundreds of other
species
about six hours into our adventure he's
gonna come down to here and jump right
omar finally seems to be worn out
i'm going home
oh he's going
he might be hung up oh here he goes
and now the real work begins what's that
new color the team replaces omar's
column checks his vital signs and
ensures that earth ranger's high-tech
science mission can continue we
essentially want to know that the
olympic peninsula is healthy
and the best way to do that is to see if
wildlife are able to move from the
olympic peninsula to the cascades and
back so far
that's not true nobody's been able to
leave the peninsula and so by putting
these gps colors on it's the best data
you can get you know we live in this
ecosystem and it is healthier and
stronger and more resilient because of
the presence of these animals
in less than an hour after being
tranquilized omar is back on his feet
nature's mighty engineer
getting back to work
for cbs morning's ben tracy on the
olympic peninsula
all right unbelievable i love that story
i really loved everything about it
unbelievable i'm from the pacific
northwest so i'm familiar with cougars
in that area but i did not know it took
that much work to track them no i didn't
know
or to film people tracking them we got a
real moment from ben tracy there they
turned to the camera what he said yeah
so put it in slow motion it's really
easy to read lips but it's fascinating
that they're even doing that and the
information that they're getting yeah
nicely done ben tracy i'm more dangerous
than i thought it would be